hey Keep Your Hands Up
come on man come on man this ain't worth
it
just let her go man
this ain't work this ain't worth it man
this ain't worth it bro come on come on
man now come on
come on man
no over here
relax
come on
hey
[Applause]
push yourself
which ain't going back
I got one on the ground here
I got it all right
you okay
hey anybody else in the house
was there any more guys in that house
how many were in there
Georgia Georgia
he's right in the middle of that block
get up you gotta help me up
foreign
yourself
[Music]
howdy oh
yes they're all out
15 services
I need a 32 over here for at 9 10.
Ardella we got a blackmail bleeding from
his face I'm 32 as fast as possible
is it here
copy I'm on C
yeah
did you guys get him
you got one of them they got they're
chasing the other two down now
do you even recognize any of them
right now to be honest like
do you live here yeah I mean what did
you just come in your house I was going
out to the car we're about to leave and
they just yeah
it is in a silver Kia like SUV like
oh
I'm feeling it now hey what's your name
sir tell them to come on Reed and
Ardella tell him to avoid Georgia
avoid Georgia
come all the way down to Reed in Ardella
copy
yeah you got to track your phone
[Music]
look go track your phone they took it
all right bro I can't feel my face
can you can you walk at all if you
helped me up if I can like oh
yeah I got you
um
at least if I worries right now man come
on we're gonna just get you over here to
this Cruiser
foreign
or you want to just
because I don't I can I can sit you in
the back in the trunk area is it going
to get something
no it's this gentleman right here okay
no he's not been shot
yeah you got to go back that way
shot man
here you can pop a squat right here if
you want
I got one over here in the car
no you got to go back the other way
foreign
car one
hey ma'am
you got to go back we gotta go back
we gotta go back
it's in my truck
foreign
come over here come over here
they mean Neville they're all over a
Neville this is 11-11 Georgia no one's
over here they're next year and over
there they're hunkered down in here
somewhere
he's on scene right now
shed back there though
in this in this house
foreign
another one
you want me to sit behind this garage
first
okay now
what you want
let me come with you
you guys
do we want to uh
did you
did you see someone run behind your
house with guns I didn't see anything I
saw a flash go past my window a little
bit before I saw you guys do you have
cameras in the back do you have a camera
in the back no I don't okay all right
just stay inside right here
the other side of your fence yeah what's
the address I
put that is
he wants this oh okay
okay
is there a way to get into your garage
no no okay
okay
hold on
this way here
oh
here right on
okay
okay here who's
there
31.
it's fine he checked behind me
if somebody look up prior system in the
call for 11 11 Georgia
no one hey it's definitely there
all right hold on hold that hold that
hold that hold that hold that don't move
now hands up hands up
foreign
[Music]
get out driver get out
watch them back watch the back don't
move
[Music]
in the back here
close your hands
close yourself
give me the other hand right now
yeah dude
hey Jack he jacked her yeah
just right now
I pulled that gun out he jacked her she
pulled in they they jacked her I saw her
pull in
they jacked her anybody else out these
are the two that's it yeah
where did they come from this 1101 she
she's she pulled in the driveway they
jacked her
and she tried to pull out
huh
they they jacked this victim
this lady yeah this lady's separate
good search
hey I pulled that I pulled that out
let's just leave that there
down
there's another pistol right there too
all right
just walk over here
two dogs
who's it 21.
legs
there's two seconds we're getting popped
in the middle tight there right now
you got anything else in there
foreign
but they were running this way so when
we saw you outside we didn't know if
yeah so we didn't know if they had you
and my dog all right
that's all we are worried about
a new band yeah
the people in the backyard yeah
well they were they were yeah
she died she's a good dog y'all from
Alabama I'm telling you she's a
good dog she looks good look
you fall she'll help you up hey every
kid on this neighborhood they come they
ask for
her yeah for real baby she's real good
that's how you raise them right
myself the kids ain't been raid right
that's true for real you're right about
that I mean how's my parents you know
live here I've been in Alabama for 15
years and I used to do all kinds of
trouble you can look at my background
but today 20 years ago
if the kids home down there my little
nephew
it ain't 2 30 yet is it uh it's four
four minutes till 2 30. oh the kid
so yeah they're probably not coming home
yeah they got to make sure they got
everybody and then they'll open it up
I know my neighbor like I I hear
everything
camera if he had work up here
so
so that's all that was going on now
they're just checking to make sure they
didn't throw anything in your backyard
hey this is your neighborhood
that's right
all right you have a good day
I think we can open up the channel great
job everybody
's going like this like pointing to his
house no he's pointing the back seat
yeah so it won't go all the way in the
back and then so the one they pulled out
of the back seat
did they come in your house and then
make you guys they barged in like in the
side door that's what I thought the
stuff is uh
just so just so I can show
um crime scene when they get here I
noticed a few things that probably are
off but
um
we'll get you in here doing
foreign
take that off you when we take it off
you stand up face that corner just put
your hands behind your back all right
bring this hand relax it for a second
um
you know like performance now I'm going
to tell you this level's kind of tight
I appreciate it
what's your name man Ricky
uh
okay
um
just shouldn't take long
oh okay that's fine there you go
that's where he got bit so get the other
arm that's where he got bit I got some
good yeah
foreign
all right
guys
[Music]
still trouble
is that bigger because I don't think
it's much bigger
all right we'll make it work
a little bit of talking I don't know
we're we're just here
thank you
all right
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
sure
hey hey good
[Music]
oh
you're here
oh you're here am I able to get another
one of these yeah okay because this is
like I don't know
I'm just running around back but yeah
that's exactly it I'll stop I'll stop up
uh next week
we'll uh
4 and 12 tonight so we'll drive by
no we're good
okay I mean I'm not here till 2 30 so
okay okay so and I don't like it because
you guys aren't in the building yeah
I'll stop up whenever okay whenever I
get a chance sometime
you got bit by uh justice
um
he's going he's making sure that happens
upstairs
watch all the uh all the stuff here go
to the right yeah
I'm trying to go through these double
doors
to the right
I'm gonna take this elevator off
foreign
pull back
right now
[Music]
thank you
we could go and pick shoes back off
and
[Music]
yeah all right let's
all right
oh my God
foreign
[Music]
for this
everything
yeah I guess so
it's cool
how's it
okay next one click loose
um
you got the show in a rose man
all right all right let's take care